hey I was gonna Bruce my name is Peter
Pat welcome to part 7 of undertale it's
another day ok so they are safe there
that's interesting
um I was very pissed off when I found
out I had to replay all this stuff but
you know what no pain a note but no game
and I really enjoyed Alfie's part I
really enjoyed Undine so I'm glad I did
it
but now we're back with a score we're
gonna fight him for hopefully the last
time I'm not gonna lie I'm getting a
little sick of a score and I feel
awkward sings name because I feel like
I'm not saying it right um also he's so
cute and I feel bad every time it's a
fun boss battle though it's really fun
um so I don't know what I'm talking
about really just feeling the day okay
here we go
a strange light fills the room Twilight
is shining through the bank I like his
little crown it's so tiny and cute he
has nothing to show up for he's a real
man King but Mook mooking murder
whatever right human it was nice to meet
you goodbye that I haven't know that it
what based mom what a miserable creature
torturing such an innocent ye do not be
afraid my Chan
it is a torii Oh your friend and
guardian at first I thought I would let
you make your own journey your
alone but I would could not stop
worrying about you your adventure must
have been treacherous and ultimately it
would burden you with a horrible choice
to leave this place you would have to
take the life of another person you
don't have to defeat a score however I
realized I cannot allow that it is not
right to sacrifice someone else someone
just simply to let someone that someone
leave here I'm just guessing what it
says is that now what I have been trying
to prevent this whole time so for now
let us suspend this man as terrible as a
score is he deserves mercy - Oh Tory you
came back do not Tory me dreamer you
pathetic whelp if you really wanted to
free our kind you can get a gun through
the barrier after you got one so taking
six souls from the humans then came back
and Fred everyone peacefully but instead
freed you made everyone live in despair
because you would rather wait here
meekly hoping another human never comes
oh this soundtrack is wonderful Tory
you're right oh my god it's so beautiful
I am miss a miserable creature but do
you think we can let these be friends
again no a score
yeah ask our human nobody fight each
other
everyone's gonna make friends or else
out out oh hello I am Toria
are you the human's friend it is nice to
meet you uh yeah nice to meet you
hey a score is that your ex ha ha ha
jeez that's rough buddy ha ha hey nobody
heard each other oh he's so cute
or she's lucky oh are you another friend
hi I'm Tori oh hello uh Aang there's two
of them this is adorable
hey nobody find anyone if anyone finds
anyone then I'll be forced to ask and
done for help
hello oh hello your majesty
hey human did ask our shape and clone
himself oh [ __ ] it says hey guys what's
up that voice
hello I think we may know each other oh
hey I recognize your voice - I am toriel
so nice to meet you
the name sands and uh same oh wait then
this must be your brother a Paris
greetings peppers this is so nice to
finally meet you
your brother has told me so much about
you
wowie I can't believe askers clone knows
who I am this is the best day of my life
or you can tell him apart
hi pepper hip hip hurts what is a
skeleton tile his roof with hmm snow
proof roof tiles Daleks that is the
actual correct answer no silly
a skeleton tells his roof with shingles
I changed my mind
this is the worst ever laughs come on
ask or it's gonna be okay
there plenty of fish in the sea yeah a
school and then it's totally right about
that fish thing
sometimes you gotta stop going after
furry boss monsters and then just get to
know a really cute fish it's a metaphor
well I think it's a good analogy
oh it's meant a dot oh my god
will you two just smooch already the
audience is dying for some romantic
action hey shut up man
the nerve of that guy right alphas alpha
D no he's right let's stir ha ha ha well
I guess if you want you then don't hold
anything back
oh God thank God thank god someone
stepped in
Oh God thought I was gonna die wait not
in front of the human alright
so sorry I got a little carried away
there mai-chan it seems that you must
stay here for a while if you must stay
in front but looking at all the great
friends he made I think I think you will
be happy here hey that reminds me
the Paris you call everyone here right
well besides up her anyway if I got here
before you how did you know how to call
everybody ha ha let's just say it's that
tiny uh oh uh uh oh god no no no god
[ __ ] damn that tiny flower
oh you're idiots but you guys were
having a little powwow
I took the human souls and now not only
are those under my power but all your
friends souls are gonna be mine too hey
hey hey and you know what the best part
is it's all your fault it's all because
you made them love you all the time you
spent listening to them encouraging them
caring about them without that they
wouldn't have come here and now with
ourselves and the human together I will
achieve my real form Hey
huh why am I still doing this don't you
get it this is all just a game if you
leave the undergrad satisfied you'll win
the game if you win you won't have to
play with me anymore
and what would I do that but this game
between us will never end this is so
creepy
I'll hold victory in front of I'll hold
victory in front of you just within your
reach and then tear it away just before
your ass bent over and over
listen if you do defeat me I'll give you
your happy ending
I'll bring your friends back I'll
destroy the barrier every will be
satisfied but that won't happen you okay
I'll keep you here no matter what oh
[ __ ] well we're stuck here even if it
means killing you a million times this
is so creepy
Oh God we're gonna die now can someone
please do something yeah
what do not be afraid my channel no
matter what happens we will always be
here to protect oh that's right human
you can win just do what I would do
believe in you hey human if you got past
me you can do anything don't so don't
worry we're with you all the way huh
you haven't beaten this guy yet come on
this weirdo got nothing on you
this is the cutest thing technically
it's impossible for you to beat him but
somehow I know you can do it human for
the future of human and monsters
you have to stay determined I'm so
[ __ ] determined right now oh my god
all of us this is the cutest thing
unbelievable
this can't be happening yeah yeah we'll
all die oh my God he's so mean listen
how did that flower get so frickin evil
wait who's this hello hello
scusi let me hear someone crying finally
I was so tired of being a flower what
who the hell you what is that their kid
had it hit are you there it's me your
best friend
oh why are we fighting her what awesome
sunshine
I like it this it's it's the end
check infinite attack legendary being
made of every soul in there holy [ __ ]
this is awesome
that is trippy oh my god oh my god aah
aah oh whoa
charges shocker breaking even her name
oh my god let's use hope you held on to
your hopes you reduce how much damage
you'll take this time you know I don't
care about destroying this better than
you and what are you Carol
oh God
all right you're super mean calls on
Kaos Sabre what is dream you think about
why you're here now you can feel the
empty space in your inventory gets
smaller
and you know what the best part of all
this is you'll do it
Jesus that did not go well and then you
lose and you'll lose to me again and
again because you love your friends
isn't that delicious determination the
power that let you get this far it's
going to be a downfall
oh god what's happening
oh god that is very terrifying okay no
all right yep I'm gonna go and pretend
I'm not here
or something no
even after that attack you're still
standing in my way wow you really are
something special don't get cocky up
until now I've only been using a
fraction of my real power let's see what
good your determination is against this
oh boy oh boy
hello oh okay
yet I can only struggle
okay we're gonna die now yep haha oh but
it refused oh my god
star goal
oh my god is so creepy if your life will
end here in a world where no one
remembers you okay
how am I supposed to dodge they use
exactly it's kind of hard
I can only struggle still you're hanging
on that's fine in a few moments you'll
forget everything to that attitude will
serve you well in next life oh I thought
I actually did it
still come on show me what you got show
me what good your determination is now
[ __ ] you struggle nothing happened you
tried to reach your save file nothing
happen
you tried again to reach your same phone
nothing happens this is so cool
see seems saving the game really is
impossible but maybe with what little
power you have you can save something
else oh my god
okay we're gonna start with undying you
reached out to Azrael sole and call out
to your friends they're in there
somewhere aren't they but in the depth
of ass real soul
something's resonating the lost soul
appears what would we do to wait as real
that's online we would fake him
you tap the la Sol lightly something
about the way you fight is familiar to
all humans will die also weary fighting
all this is so cool I love this and I
love the soundtrack the lost souls
dancing let's let's use a recipe you
asked a lost soul to teach you how to
cook she doesn't know why but she kind
of wants you to teach you how your a
real enemy [ __ ] dance dance
revelution all night with you undying
it's clash you clashed against the last
soul with all your mind
she recognizes your fighting spirit
suddenly memories are flooding back well
some humans are ok I guess ok so we did
done and undying you feel something
faintly resonating with as we okay so we
saved and then let's move on to my Paris
the death of the vice-regal soul
something is resonating the lost soul
has appeared oh it sounds as well ok
let's start with that prepares what's a
puzzle you asked a lost soul for help
with the puzzle he doesn't know why but
he really wants to help I must capture I
helmet just give it up
I did oh god I not good with me oh come
on
ah I got lucky there the lost souls
stand there let's focus on one of them
at a time
umm I guess I guess a good good pun you
told the lost soul a bad pun about
skeletons it seems to hate it but the
other lost souls seem to like it and
everyone will might even try Oh God oh
boy oh oh oh my Jesus
the last soul standing a bad an instant
insulted lost somehow it seems flattered
by this you'll never see him again
oh come on should not have gotten hit
there let's add show another did we do
recipe you asked a lost soul to cook
something for you
suddenly it's memories are flooding back
seeing how nicely you trivets brother
the other lost soul remembers to no wait
you're my friend I could never capture
you now
I'm rooting for you kid you feel
something resonating that that's real
that did not go too well did it no and
did not
what could it be
okay let's do uh
I feel like I should do it oh god this
is my last oh God Oh
toriel then I don't want to [ __ ] up now
the lost souls appear
I'm I suppose attack
okay well I fought özgür so many times I
feel like I'm pretty good at it man
uh-huh
you hug the last I'll tell her that
you're going to see it again something
about this is so familiar
toriel is not attacking it
the lost souls dancing
so refighting the kid is that it because
I it looks like toriel if you ask me
Oh No
we refuse to fight her just like at the
beginning oh boy I'm so full of [ __ ]
aren't I worse oh we already did
Merson suddenly her memories are
flooding back seeing I remember you the
male lost soul tried hard to remember
YouTube pages upon you net you are our
future and that heel is so that's good
we only have alphas left within the
depth of Ezreal soul something is
resonating the lost soul appeal this is
so emotional I feel feel like building
an and nerd out us his lost soul what a
favorite cartoon is she can barely hold
back from giving you an enormous answer
you hate me don't you oh yeah oh God
should have mettaton be hearing the lost
souls dancing how about we quiz him you
barely hold she barely holds back you
mean man sir
nailed it
carriage
and she remembers it's all flooding back
no that's not true my friends like me
and I like you too
this is very anime you feel your friends
soul resonating in a sphere I don't
really understand the point of attacking
they [ __ ] it and I don't know how to
dodge that attack someone else strangely
as your friends remembered you something
else began resonating within the soul
stronger and stronger it seems that
there's still sorry I'm waiting for my
car to get fixed making sure I don't
miss a call and if you're also very into
this it seem that there's still one less
person that needs to be saved but who
suddenly you realize you reach out and
call their name huh what are you doing
wait oh god it's about us now isn't it
oh my god
that yeah so someone else helped us
you feel your friends soul resonating
with Azrael what did you do
what's this feeling what's happening to
me no I don't need anyone well I'm just
chillin over here stop it
get away from me do you hear me I'll
tear you apart
please don't actually pierce do you know
why I'm doing this why I keep fighting
you to keep you around
oh it's not attacking me anymore doing
this because you're special pants you're
the only one that understands me you're
the only one who's own any fun to play
with anymore
starting to understand but I'm waiting
for more pieces I'm doing this because I
care about your parents I care about you
more than anyone else
not ready for this to end now ready for
you to lean now ready to say goodbye
just someone like you again
so please stop doing this and just let
me win
Oh God
haha oh they can go on forever I suppose
I'm solo huge I'm so afraid
yeah pips hi hey I'm so sorry I always
was a crybaby wasn't I
pit's I know you're not actually paired
sorry it's been gone for all no are they
breaking the fourth wall again this is
saddest thing I ever heard um what what
is your name
frisk that's a nice name
frisk I haven't felt like this for a
long time that's a flower I was soulless
I like the power to love other people
however with everyone's soul inside me
I'm not I not only have my own
compassion back but I can feel every
other monsters as well they all care
about each other so much and they care
about you too
frisk I wish I could tell you how
everyone feels about you the perish sons
Undine alfea's toriel monsters are weird
maybe though they barely know you
it feels like they are all really love
you frisk right I understand if you
can't forgive me
I understand if you hate me is so
strange and horrible I heard you I heard
so many people friends family bystanders
there's no excuse for what I've done of
course we're gonna forgive frisk come on
you're gonna make me cry again besides
even if you do forgive me I can't keep
these Souls inside of me at least I can
do is return them but first there's
something I have to do right now I can
feel everyone's heart beating as one
they're all burning with the same desire
with everyone's power with everyone's
determination it's time for monsters to
finally go free Oh No
is he gonna sacrifice himself
it was at the barrier yeah
the barrier was destroyed
frisk I have to go net without the power
everyone's Souls
I can't keep tip maintaining this form
and a little while
I'll turn back into a flower I'll stop
being myself I'll stop being able to
feel love again so fresh it's best if
you just forget about me okay just go be
with the people who love you so sad what
the [ __ ] happens I don't want to let go
laughs you're going to do a great job
okay no matter what you do everyone will
be there for you okay well my time is
running out goodbye
by the way frisk take care of mom and
dad for me okay oh my god who the feels
just came right away ah this is all just
a bad dream
place weekend
frisk I like that name better than hits
oh you would awake
thank goodness we were so worried it
felt like you were out forever yeah any
longer and I would have freaked out
tell us next time you decide to take a
nap okay yeah you may prepare this cry
like a baby what I didn't cry I don't
cry me neither I didn't I didn't cry
before I just caught something in my eye
yeah you have a nice socket ha ha ha ha
ha now the important part is that frisk
is all right here frisk why not drink
some frisk tea it'll make you feel
better how about we give them space
first they must be very exhausted though
from what I'm not certain frisk we do
not remember exactly what happened there
was a flower and then everything went
white but now the barrier is gone when
you are ready we will all return to the
surface it seems the door to the east
would lead us there now but before then
perhaps you might want to take a walk
you can say goodbye to all your
wonderful friends do as you wish we will
all wait for you here
start with escort how to frisk sorry
about all mistake trying to take
yourself I feel very bad about it I hope
we can simply pass hey don't worry about
ASCO think everybody's try to kill a
frisk at least once
oh I see in that case I'm not sorry
frisk ass gone
that's not what I meant frisk um you got
to tell me do you think a score in
toriel are ever gonna get back together
yes yeah yeah that's that's what I hoped
you just think about how cute they might
step in together it's quickly becoming
my number one ship of all time there it
is Torian gay turay my old boss and his
ex-wife ah that sounds a lot less cool
over seven Oh what do you want to do now
that we're all free we have the whole
world to explore now well of course I'm
going to go out and um no I should be
honest I'm gonna stay inside and watch
anime like a total loser
that's the spirit everyone a celebration
to being losers huh the Paris has the
right idea losing the frisk is the best
thing never happened to me I'm glad that
we huh what is it ask her um what Sun
anime oh my god we're getting oh my god
frisk please help me explain what anime
is to ask her you see it's like cartoon
but
with swords so it's like cartoon but
with swords golly that sounds neato
where is this where can i see the anime
huh Lana I think we had I have someone
on my phone here look at this oh that's
the wrong I never mind
si hentai golly were those two robots
kissing boy taking a lot of Technology
sure is something isn't it yeah sure is
I had that exact same video I know
exactly what they're talking about
frisk Tori was telling me how she made
what scotch par for you oh I should bake
it for everyone some time oh that sounds
really good cooking
can I help wait a second can I help you
certainly a refund to cook together
on a second thought maybe I'll order
pizza
toriel hello frisk Alf is upgrading my
phone I'm having a lot of fun with the
texting feature sons check out this one
oh man
Tori that's brutal I can't believe the
Queen Esther dad and also that she's a
huge dog you too - are you two are two
feet away from each other why are you
texting what are you not prepared
we are texting for a good reason why is
that well because we're huge dollars
cents please do not say that you are not
to do you're more of a bonehead Wow
those funds are even less funny coming
from her then why are you smiling
it's a pity smile the Paris my man
so ASCO how about making a member of the
royal god me remember ever I've been
well appears now that the war is over we
might not need a Royal Guard anymore
what that what is the part of the humans
quest they they churn it all the way and
I'm stayin outta memory dude Royal Guard
Shanaya system worst possible addicts
hahaha it tells me to go ease but I'm
like South what ok I suppose we can I
don't have to save [ __ ] it
hi guys I love you [ __ ] it game is like
save already if you leave here your
adventure will be really over your
friends will follow you out of the
anagram I'm ready yeah here we are
humans and monsters oh my isn't it
beautiful everyone wow it's even better
than on TV way better than I ever
imagined frisk you live with this the
sunlight is so nice in the air is so
fresh
I really feel alive hey sans what's that
giant ball
we wake all that the Sun my frame that's
the Sun wowie I can't believe I'm
finally meeting the Sun I could stand
here and watch this for hours
yes it is beautiful
is it that but we should really think
about what comes next
all right everyone this is the beginning
of a bright new future an era of peace
between humans and monsters frisk I have
something to ask of you will you act as
our own bad side bar and buy Center for
the humans what if I say no yeah first
will be the ambassador and I had the
greater purpose will be the best masking
I'll go make a good first impression
well someone's got to keep him from
getting into trouble see you guess where
he walked the other way
[ __ ] sake men do I have to do everything
prepares wait hey on day wait up
should I do something well I gotta go
she's still pissed I guess she just
needs time it seems that everyone is
quite eager to set up risk you came from
this world right so you must have a
place to return do you not what will you
do now oh I don't know the answer of
that one I guess I have places to go
ah I see well I hope that I am not
keeping you oh god now I feel bad but I
picked the wrong one frisk see you ran
I just feel like they're better off
without me you know alright maybe I made
the wrong decision there in the end but
that was an amazing good end name and
really was worth the good ending um oh
man
I can't believe I almost did not play
this game just because everyone was so
worked out about this game like there
was literally like a tumblr post just
with like thousands of reblog be like
Pierce don't play this game work or like
[ __ ] played this game I'm gonna be a
pear stop this is ridiculous I don't
understand cuz it's such a wonderful
game how can you be so hateful about
spreading it around you know it's really
weird
I don't know that really understand all
the fanbase of it and I'm glad I didn't
let them ruin it for me cuz I would have
missed out on an amazing game if I did
uh that was that was [ __ ] awesome it
really was I wish I knew less also going
into it because I think normally what I
would have done is I probably start
fighting and done some acting because I
think that's what the game was kind of
designed to do but everyone told you to
do the pacifist run so
I think I would have enjoyed playing
through it twice more if I if I didn't
come in knowing that but other than that
I am just so impressed how what like it
it performs so Oh over that it overdid
itself so many times I felt like it just
kept getting better and better and it's
you can tell give a lot a lot of thought
into this game it was a it was a
pleasure and it's a it feels like this
is the kind of game that's gonna go down
to as one of one of the classics oh
excuse me I really hope you bros enjoyed
watching this playthrough with me
I am I had a lot of fun I hope you had
fun as well
and
I don't think I have much else to say I
guess we're just gonna sit through that
the credits together because I feel like
that's appropriate
my car is so what here there we go
I love mettaton
who needs arms with legs like that am i
right that was such a fun boss - can't
wait to download a soundtrack of this
we have a spider bus
hahaha use your imagination Thanks
astigmatism
that kid was awesome
I really didn't think the fields would
hit me so hard
beautiful
no no flowey no are you are you know
yeah you just had to have a final troll
I mean we haven't even done this special
thanks yet ready let's end all of this
free kick no please please
I have infinite help anyway hahaha
I tucked up
my god a lot of special things a
yeah I'm definitely reading all these
names
oh my god
why am I doing this
how many special thanks sir Kickstarter
like without annoyed its that annoyed
touched credits okay
thanks to friends and families for
supporting us a no detail team thanks to
you the player from the bottom our
hearth without you all of this would be
impossible good night
good night indeed is that no okay um I
don't owe that oh that's always sweet
Oh such a beautiful theme soundtrack was
amazing that a gameplay was so much fun
it was refreshing all the way through
and the story was [ __ ] awesome the
characters is just classic like you love
them um there's nothing I would really
change about the game I think it was
perfect like it was the only part was
like the lab because I just wanted to
finish the game and get to the point and
then it was just like a bunch of [ __ ]
finding Keys quest which I thought it
was a little weird I think that was the
only part while playing the game where I
felt like that but I was probably cuz I
was very hungry and that dog is the
cutest thing Thank You brothers for
watching again I don't I don't see
anything else happening there might be
um I hope I'm not a big jerk we're not
waiting and I'm got places to go got
things to do let me know what you think
about this format if you want to keep me
to keep this I'll probably do it because
as I explained before and takes the
pressure off and I can just focus on
playing that game and I think there's a
lot of other great games out there as
well that I've neglected because I
didn't know how to make it into a series
so that's it for me for now I really I
really really hope this worked out but
either way it was fun fun time so that's
all that matters right they could both
stay awesome